chaos in Venezuela where supply
shortages have been running rampant
inflation is of the highest in the world
yesterday the venezuelan congress
declared that President Nicolas maduro's
government has staged a coup by blocking
a drive to recall the president in a
legislative session which was
interrupted when his supporters stormed
the congressional chamber now opposition
lawmakers vowed to put Maduro on trial
after a court I guess you can call it
friendly to the Maduro administration on
Thursday suspended their campaign to
collect signatures to hold a referendum
on removing the very unpopular president
lawmaker Julio Borquez said that the
opposition led Congress is now in open
rebellion after a majority of its
members voted that the decision
constituted a coup with government
participation huge shortages of all
sorts of supplies in Venezuela some of
the world's highest inflation some polls
say nearly eighty percent of voters want
Nicolas Maduro out and Venezuela's
Constitution allows the current
opposition to call for a referendum to
revoke the president from the government
there's actually a lot written about
this online basically there are three
stages to call for a referendum in
Venezuela first the opposition has to
collect at least one percent of
signatures from registered voters in the
whole country after that the Electoral
Council has to validate the signatures
the opposition again has to collect
twenty percent of signatures from
registered voters in a national context
this is insane after see any the
Electoral Council validates those
signatures uh they must actually call
for the referendum now after the
opposition collected that one percent of
signatures and you can imagine if eighty
percent of the country's voters really
want Maduro out you're going to easily
be able to get one percent of the
signatures of the countries are
registered voters they started the
process to collect that second group of
signatures and then this to
Cree was made that it has to be regional
so instead of being just twenty percent
of the whole country you need twenty
percent in each of the 23 Venezuelan
states this is not only much more
difficult to achieve but it is being
argued by the opposition completely
unconstitutional so now there's a push
to take legal action the country is
descending into even further chaos and
this is part of the problem that I've
been talking about in Venezuela for a
very long time not only is there no
press freedom in Venezuela there is no
judicial freedom the court system is
completely controlled by the government
by the administration there's a recent
Planet Money about why Venezuela has
imploded I would encourage you to check
it out it's a very good episode and you
know when when Hugo Chavez past I was
very clear that i did not see Hugo
Chavez as the big progressive populist
Savior that some progressives in the
u.s. saw him as and people went nuts on
me I actually had people Pat you
wouldn't know this cuz you weren't with
the show at the time my commentary on
Venezuela actually led to some members
writing to me saying David you're not
progressive because you criticized Hugo
Chavez you have a government in
Venezuela that arms and sponsors gangs
to deal with issues extra judicially you
have total control total corruption of
the court system the media system is an
absolute and total joke and every time I
would talk about it in talking about
Hugo Chavez and in talking about Nicolas
Maduro some portion of our audience
would email and they would leave
voicemail saying David we really don't
like you my wife and I my buddy and I
I'm listening to the show I'm so angry
just because you see populist rhetoric
doesn't mean it's truly for the people
just because a movement or a government
or a country's regime admit excuse me
administration is ostensibly left that
doesn't mean that it's actually
progressive and there's no better
example than what we've seen in
Venezuela this is relatively common in
Argentina this is something I'm growing
up being from our
Tina and uh growing up around political
discussion about South America this is
something I am very very familiar with
and if people want to get mad at me
because I don't see the Javas and now
Maduro line as progressive I see them as
strong arm authoritarians with sort of
populist rhetoric if that really angers
you then I would encourage you to
research a little more I am just the
messenger ladies and gentlemen Venezuela
descending into chaos completely
unsurprising to anybody who's been
following it we will continue to follow
it and tell you what ultimately happens
gamefly is sort of like Netflix for
video games they have over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one xbox 360 ps4
ps3 wii and a bunch of other platforms
and you can play as many games as you
want for one monthly fee and if you find
some games you want to keep you can buy
them for a low use price there's never
any due dates or late fees and our
audience can get a free 30-day trial at
gamefly offer.com / TDPS the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the david pakman show audience and
support our show by going to gamefly
offer.com / TDPS